love this man love his work
can't wait to hear what he's got to say
about the ncaa tournament that just
concluded
he is from the worldwide leader in
sports been there forever and a day so
far long ago that i worked with him
there many many many many times back
here on the rich eisen show on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line the great
jay billis how are you jay
i am doing great rich how are you i'm
doing fine uh i'm hanging in there man
what a tournament right i mean it was
just terrific what what leaps out at you
from the tournament writ large jbl
that's how it was it was probably the
most unpredictable tournament that i can
recall maybe there has been one or two
um
the only thing that was predictable is
that you had
sort of the big shots advanced to the
second weekend but but the the little
guy that advanced was so little it it
sort of upended everything and took all
the air out of the room with that story
being saint peter's so you had a 15 seed
that made it to the elite eight for the
first time ever
but outside of saint peter's the rest of
the the sweet 16 was uh 13
um
major conference teams gonzaga and
houston both of whom were in the final
four last year and could hardly be
called cinderellas
so it was um while it was volatile
uh you know having north carolina make
it to the championship game and and uh
you know an upset of a number one
you know in the second round and then an
upset of number one sweet 16 and all
that we only had one number one seed
make it through the final four it was
one number one two number twos
in north carolina as a number as a
number eight
it was unpredictable but predictable in
the uh
in the way that we had a ton of big
shots
that were the uh sort of the uh
unpredictable ones like when that when
double-digit seeds that advance advance
to the sweet 16 or
you know michigan
and iowa state
uh and and teams like that um i don't i
don't call them you know the little
engine that could so it was it was
somewhat predictable in that fashion and
then kansas coming back last night what
what what did bill self say to that team
at halftime do you think what what
adjustments did they make
jay yeah i think they just talked about
it being a long game and they hadn't
played well and they didn't make
north carolina feel them defensively so
they were much more physical
in the second half uh they guarded the
ball much better
uh thought dejuan harris their point
guard their best perimeter defender was
much more active pressure in the ball
and they got some steals and they really
forced uh north carolina uh they took
away their pace and so their offense
became a little bit more one-dimensional
they had to make individual plays
and they wound up taking some
questionable jump shots instead of
attacking uh the paint uh whether it's
off the dribble or off the pass and and
you know they have some foul issues i
mean leaky black got foul trouble that
took them off ochai obagi
but they just got some better better
performances but one defensively and
then they did a better job on the glass
even though they got out rebounded
pretty badly
they didn't give up as many in the first
half they got out rebounded i think by
nine and they gave up eight offensive
rebounds but
north carolina scored 18 points off
those so they converted on everything in
the second half carolina got some
offensive rebounds but but they weren't
able to convert on them uh just because
kansas was so much tougher and converged
to the ball and did a way better job
defensively and their attack was more
concerted to get it inside and you know
they posted christian brown they got the
ball to david mccormack and then remy
martin came off the bench and knocked
down uh several threes like he had 11
points if i remember right in the second
half to have 14 overall he banked one in
the first half but there was only three
uh but they were just better and they
held carolina to 27
in the second half and they ate into
that lead pretty quickly and put a lot
of game pressure on carolina they never
you know they couldn't really respond
and um uh so yeah
i thought kansas was you know the better
team but caroline had been playing so
well they clearly could have won that
game no matter what
uh but uh you know having baikot
compromised you know baikots had that
that bomb ankle still had
15 points 15 rebounds um yeah he's just
had an extraordinary year unbelievable i
mean he had the second most rebounds in
the history of the ncaa tournament he
was he was spectacular and was that a
loose floorboard that got him last night
jeff i saw that i i saw that rich on
social media and i couldn't really tell
uh what that was i mean he you know his
ankle was screwed up anyways right could
have been a contributing factor it could
have been the whole thing and you know
who knows i don't know whether it's some
optical illusion but i can't imagine
that was a loose floorboard but if there
was
uh that's something that they need to
take into account remedy but i hope it
wasn't that but it it it was hard for me
to tell like i you know when when i saw
that on social media you know loose
floorboard how could the answerable do
this
uh like kind of i couldn't believe it
and i just couldn't see it well enough
to know if there's any truth to it and
then i could say where where's kansas go
from here but it's kansas city jay right
i heard that one right that's where they
go next beauty that was a beauty
you know obviously emmer just misspoke
but uh
but given the job he's done that that
that didn't help his uh the public
perception of him as a competent
professional
well put jay bill is here uh on the rich
eisen show so are you because of the
nature of your profession and how you
play it straight and you just play it
right down the middle are you
uh above the duke carolina fray do you
get the texts from carolina people on a
night like saturday night or
or you're just uh you're out of that mix
because you've been sort of impartial
for as long as you've been overall i
think i am above the fray honestly like
i really don't care who wins these games
that's up to the participants and i know
so many people there at carolina and and
i count hubert davis among my most
valued friends so
when that game was really interesting
feeling for me i was doing the game for
espn i was doing all the games for espn
international which uh my nil deals in
sweden to have skyrocketed it's really
fantastic
uh
but but when the buzzer went off i was i
was so happy for hubert and uh and
and those carolina players like duke and
carolina recruit the same guys it's not
like they're you know they're foreign to
one another as far as you know they're
different people or anything
the fans can go crazy all they want to
and they should crow and use this as a
trump card because the duke people would
have done the same thing
but but then the contrast of of having
coach k's last game and watching him
walk off the floor
um and look i've said this i mean i i
didn't i wasn't sad about it uh about it
being the end for coach k because i get
it he's 75 years old it's time for him
to move to the next stage of his life
but but it was poignant and and i did
have this overwhelming feeling of
gratitude
obviously on a personal level having
known him since i was 17 and all the
things that that he's done for me and
and what my life
is because of him
but also for
you know just as a uh somebody who loves
basketball
that you know whether it's when nick
saban leaves or uh when bear bryant
retired or when john wooden retired you
know you have a an appreciation for what
he's meant for the game
and uh you know i think rich we're all
kind of guys our age are all kind of
fortunate you know we lived through jack
nicholas and tiger woods
and we lived through uh kareem magic
bird jordan
and lebron and durant um and and we've
lived through uh dean smith and coach k
and for me john wooden when i was a kid
um and now the younger guys that like
jay wright that are that are you know
taking the baton over um it's really
been kind of an extraordinary time
uh at least for our lifetimes to to have
like you know i'm 58 and coach k has
been at duke for 42 years um and and my
you know my whole adult life has been
you know my relationship with with the
school is way better because he stayed
there and i i really believe this that
my relationship with my former teammates
and the guys who have played there
is way stronger
because we all played for the same coach
that there's a commonality there that uh
that most players don't
uh get to experience and uh you know the
guys at syracuse have but but very few
others have had that kind of common
experience that they share how do you
think jay i don't know if you've spoken
to him yet how do you think the way it
ended is going to sit with coach okay
you know the same i i i don't know if
it'll be magnified because it's the last
time or magnified because it was north
carolina versus another you know
michigan state that knocked him out or
texas tech or something you know i think
every year when when they lose
just like for every every coach every
team there's a there's a down period
where you you know you you have hey what
if i'd done this or that one really hurt
um
this one has a little bit more
they have it has more layers to it so i
don't i don't really know the answer to
that i haven't spoken to him yet
um you know i sent him a i talked to
danny ferry about this we had dinner the
other night and i said you're gonna
you're gonna call him uh because i'm
thinking about should i call because i
don't want to bother him right but danny
said no i'm gonna send him a note and i
had actually just done that i sent him a
son of a letter but uh but i'll catch up
with him in the next next several days
just to you know sort of uh debrief the
whole thing and
and uh and let him know you know the
feeling when when he was walking off and
uh and see what he has to say but it's
just sort of a weird it's kind of a
weird time like
he didn't just announce that he was
leaving otherwise i would have i would
have called and been there and all that
stuff it's been a year-long process so
we've had a lot a lot longer to wrap our
heads around this one so it's a little
bit of a different you know different
than the the normal retirement of an
icon you know a mount rushmore type
well i i mean i'll ask it anyway i know
the answer to it but i'll ask it anyway
since there are many who are wondering
the way that it ended is something that
coach k uh
won't be able to countenance to the
point where he'll say you know what i
want to do one more year and tell john
shire
you got this uh a year from now do you
think there's any chance of that
happening zero yeah zero uh but if he
does it i hope he does it
um
if he does come back i hope he does it
on one of tom brady's most important
days
uh
because brady announced he was coming
back during the bracket reveal of
selection sunday
and uh and so i i think coach k
just time it to to
one of brady's most important
how to get it out there because you know
free agency was about to begin he
couldn't lose anybody you know what i
mean like so you're saying he should
have just waited until the
all the regions were announced or
something like that
right you know i'm sure that's what
brady's going to say that that it had to
do more with free agent signings and
making sure that tampa bay was as
competitive as possible
so that that he could come back to the
best possible team i'm sure that's going
to be the narrative rich but the truth
is
as a helmet-wearing uh you know purveyor
of that sadistic ground acquisition game
that is nothing more than a crypto
fascist metaphor for war
uh that was just about that was just
about demeaning the round ball game that
is that is far more beautiful
uh than
football uh that that's all that was and
and let's just be honest about it
well i mean i i think you're being
honest about it if you use the word
crypto fascist in relation you know to
the conversation jay i didn't think you
were mentioning anything it's just a war
it is just a metaphor for war uh you
know they talk about uh
it's a ground acquisition game that's
all it is
and they talk about throwing the bomb
and it's very militaristic and
basketball is a game of balletic
movement
uh you know we don't have committee
meetings between each play uh you have
to play offense and defense
uh without a break um and and you know
they're they're look football is a great
game
uh and it's certainly a wonderful
distraction
while while basketball is on its hiatus
but uh but let's let's be honest it is
not the same type of the same type of
wonderful beautiful game that is the
second most popular game in the world
while football happens to be popular
here
but uh but nowhere else on the planet i
like your agenda jay that you've brought
to the table here today i really you
know i i admire it i very very much it's
just objective honesty rich it's not an
agenda uh you know i'm i'm a true seller
oh my god j bill is here uh on the rich
eisen show you have caused me to uh
to actually um
need to clear my throat um so before i
let you go um what what what did you
make
of north carolina's run at the very end
of the day jay bilas and how that what
that means for the program writ large
with hubert davis you know it was a
great example rich of several things but
but one for for any team that your
record and the analytics of your
performance during the season can tell
you what you've accomplished but it
doesn't necessarily tell you or tell
others what you're capable of doing yes
and hubert davis had this unshakable
belief in their ability to accomplish
something great and even when they were
struggling
still believe that they were a
championship caliber
team
and and i can tell you that among the
basketball community he was he was a a
gang of one in that
and uh i'm sure his players believed him
and telling him that but nobody outside
the program believed that in january or
early february
but but also like hubert davis to me and
i got the chance to work with him uh
closely for seven years when he was with
the with espn that we worked together on
college game day and other things
and and honestly rich i don't know a
better person than hubert davis uh he is
he's a great example that you can be
a a nice
um
empathetic thoughtful person in in every
way and be a cutthroat competitor uh
when it's time to compete and those two
things aren't mutually exclusive uh he's
he's all class all the time
and uh and you know i was so happy for
him
and he said one thing that you know we
do these interviews like on sunday you
sit both the championship game coaches
down and and i i had asked him about um
you know roy williams and being at all
the games and all that he said you know
i haven't really really been able to
watch coach williams uh on this ride he
says but i have been watching my family
and he talked about his his kids didn't
see him playing the nba
and and they get to see him now uh
accomplish something like this
and he's really enjoyed that enjoyed
having his family along for this ride
and it of all the things that that i
admire about hubert and i said this
about him in the first couple years we
work together he's the best father i
have ever seen
and it's not close um
he puts you know all of us who think
we're we're decent dads
are put to shame by hubert davis best
dad in in in history it's it's absurd
how good of a dad he is
i just took my best dad ever sign off my
desk that's when my guys are laughing
yeah
chapel hill because uh you know your
second best dad i'll i'll i'll feed that
to you but but hubert is taking the best
dad
before i let you go jay uh which player
will will make the biggest impact in the
nba which one did we just see in this
tournament that you might be talking
about come draft night um in a couple
months
or or the following seasons in the
association the top three in the draft
are going to be chet holgren of gonzaga
jabari smith of auburn and paolo bancaro
of of duke
they're the youngest and that seems to
be the way the game has gone is is who
has the highest ceiling for the future
but those three guys are extraordinary
talents and it's it's gonna be basically
what do you like the best because all of
them make a pretty good case for number
one
but this it's a pretty deep draft class
you know jayden ivy of purdue is is
fantastic
it's not it's not a draft of point
guards as much as it is wings and front
core players
but uh but there's a ton of talent in
this draft and and if it were me right
now i'd probably go with jabari smith of
uh of auburn he's the the closest thing
offensively to uh to durant he's not
durant but he's the closest thing with
with his ability to score and shoot it
uh he's gonna have a great nba career if
he stays healthy and then the first
person to see homegrown when he's uh in
the in the nba isn't his head coach it's
the strength coach right i mean isn't
that the first guy he'll he'll have to
be introduced to in the end yeah he'll
have to get stronger i don't think his
body is going to carry a ton of weight
he's always going to be going to be
lanky and thin right uh but with his
ability to block shot it's hard for
offensive players to get into his body
there are things that that right now you
can do against him but
um but because of his talent level his
ability to rebound and handle it block
shots and
shoot threes and all that he's uh he's
in a lot of ways built for the nba but
his body does give you a little bit of
pause you just don't see guys built like
that very often he's kind of a porzingis
type
uh body and there were a lot of
questions about porzingis
it would be able to handle the pounding
in the nba and so there are a lot of
a lot of old school guys in the nba that
that you know his his body style gives
him a little bit of pause and it does
for me too you just don't see it very
often jay really appreciate all the
times you've called in uh every single
time you're uh you make me smarter uh
and laugh and um i appreciate it my
friend uh next time here in person out
in southern california let's do it
i'll be there in july and i'd love to
come in i'd love it thanks again jay
appreciate it we'll chat again soon
see you brother thank you that's j bill
it's the great j bill is here on the
rich eisens show didn't see the answer
to that coach k uh question
being a broadside in brady's direction
wow
crypto fascist hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here